disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
if you've been listening to my podcast
for a while if you've been watching the
show for a while you know that on this
show i try to
i try to do a lot of different things
but for our purposes today
i always
want to be clear when i tell you that we
know something to be true
that we suspect something to be true
based on some evidence and data
or that we're just guessing and
speculating
we can now move from
mere speculation to
we can suspect based on early data
that the omicron variant or the omnicron
as some call it it's actually omicron
that the omicron variant which led to
market turmoil over the last couple of
weeks
uh panic everywhere
might actually be
less severe in terms of its rate at
which it causes severe disease
than the delta variant that is
potentially
a very welcome change to this trajectory
of the covid pandemic now i'm going to
tell you what
is making us suspect that
and i'm going to be clear about the fact
that we are still missing some of the
data that we need
we are now close to two weeks since the
big kind of coming out party of omicron
which took control of the corporate news
cycle starting uh on and right after
thanksgiving lasted several days and now
sort of in subsequent forms has lasted
um nearly two weeks dr anthony fauci who
heads up the nih lead infectious disease
doctor in the united states
is now calling the early signs
encouraging about omicron
without question
this variant appears to be as or up to
significantly more contagious than delta
that's
sort of like one side of the equation
it's spreading rapidly
it's spreading very rapidly and
hospitalizations are going up
but the data we have so far is that the
hospitalizations are going up because of
delta delta driving hospitalizations
it does not appear at this time
that omicron is actually leading to
significant hospitalization at all it is
spreading quickly it may ultimately
out-compete delta in terms of infections
but for right now
and dr fauci concurs
it is encouraging that while it appears
to be more contagious it seems to be
less severe
now the dream scenario would be
that omicron in exchange for being
wildly contagious
is more of a cold than a serious virus
with a death rate close to one percent
as cobit has been throughout this
pandemic that means it will spread
but fewer people comparatively will end
up in the hospital and die that's the
hope and we don't yet know dr fauci was
on cnn this weekend where he said quote
thus far it does not look like there's a
great degree of severity to it but we
have really got to be careful before we
make any determinations that it is less
severe or it really doesn't cause
any severe
illness so this is really the key thing
to understand
if you
look at something for 15 seconds
and then make a conclusion
you are almost certainly not operating
even with the full data that we have and
the full data that we have is still not
as full as it ultimately needs to be if
you just look and you see wow cases are
spiking hospitalizations are up omicron
must be a disaster but remember
we expected to some degree that cases
and hospitalizations were going to spike
during the winter the question is
is the news about omicron from nearly
two weeks ago
the reason for the spiking
hospitalizations and it appears for now
that the answer is no
it is delta driving hospitalizations in
the north of the u.s not omicron so
still
understand that if omicron is as
contagious as it might be
it will infect a lot more people so even
if the hospitalization rate is lower
you might still end up with more people
hospitalized in terms of raw numbers
some of them will end up in the icu
some of them will die
uh just imagine i mean you know this is
made up but
imagine that we determined omicron is
three times as contagious but half as
deadly
that still means more people are going
to end up in the hospital a lower
percentage of those that get the virus
but more people will end up in the
hospital lastly we also have to remember
that the prevailing narratives about
these variants at the start are often
untrue and that's why i've been going
out of my way i mean nearly two weeks
now that i've been saying
right now all we have is anecdotes
now all we have is preliminary data
that's where we are right now with delta
initially it was all sort of muted it
was more neutral it was starting to
spread in other countries and
hospitalizing a lot of people but there
was not really the panicked media
coverage and then a huge spike with tons
of deaths hit the united states and
basically everywhere and then the media
coverage changed with omicron the
coverage started with complete and total
panic now it seems it may be more mild
still could end up going some other way
the point is two weeks in we don't know
and for now i wouldn't be taking any
chances on the assumption that it's more
mild in a few weeks we will know for
sure now over time
this is how
viruses stop being a pandemic we learned
this in our interview with columbia
university's virologist vincent
racanello
in general
viral evolution tends to be
more contagious and less severe
but it can still be deadly for years and
years and years now from a
kind of sociological standpoint the
level of fatigue with this is obviously
very very high a lot of people just
feeling i'm throwing in the towel
it's time to move on i'm not going to
pay attention anymore i'm going to do
whatever that's not where i am right now
as i've said in bits and pieces
i got my third shot
early data is that that third shot is
very effective at preventing you from
getting sick at all
um
much more than just the two doses we're
still waiting on more data there but
that's hopeful any place that says masks
recommended
i'm wearing a mask
i'm not going to movie theaters i'm not
going to concerts i'm not going to
sporting events and these types of large
events i am going to restaurants indoors
if the tables aren't very close together
i care less about do i have to wear a
mask up to the counter to order i care
more about am i going to sit for an hour
really really close to another table i'm
not going to those i'm not going to bars
where people are hanging out for hours
i am of course flying but with a mask
that's legally required
and i'm seeing friends who who i know
are vaccinated
and whose daily risk level is acceptable
to me
they either work from home or you know
have a low level of risk indoors i am
doing that
it is true you know the the rights
talking points are always they grapple
with a kernel of truth and go too far
isolation
has consequences but for a long time for
me the risk balance told me i'm going to
stick with the isolation with what we
now know
and having three doses
i'm more comfortable trading some risk
for decreased isolation and more
socialization everybody has to run this
calculation for themselves but the key
is
run it with actual accurate information
which we are still gathering when it
comes to the omicron variant
a new york city is now putting in place
the strictest vaccine mandate in the
country this is bill de blasio new york
city mayor on his way out remember with
incoming mayor eric adams replacing him
soon here's what's going on in new york
city
starting on december 27th and maybe
specifically timed in advance of new
year's eve new york city's vaccine
mandate will expand to all private
sector workers
the what counts as vaccination will
change to two doses rather than one
kids age 5 to 11
will be subject to the vaccination
mandate and all will have to show proof
of full vaccination meaning two doses to
do indoor dining and to go to other
activities starting december 14th which
is a week from today um this is all sort
of happening in the context of omicron
even as we don't know exactly what the
outlook is as i just told you it appears
to be more contagious and early data
suggests it is less severe now there's a
couple of questions here one of the big
questions is okay great it's a vaccine
mandate vaccinate or else or else what
and it's not totally clear yet and the
or else what
some legal experts are saying is what
could determine whether this stands up
to a court challenge now i'm i'm just
being upfront uh on the one hand for
these types of mandates
just actual straight-up mandates being
legal
is this i believe it's a jacobson v
massachusetts case from 1903 and the
smallpox vaccine that continues to be
what we point to and say
these these mandates are legal
when the idea of a federal mandate was
brought up
there were questions about well
would jacobson v massachusetts
which was a local mandate in the city of
cambridge i believe it was cambridge
would that apply
to a federal vaccine man yeah well it's
not really clear
well it seems that state and local
vaccine mandates are more likely to pass
muster but then another wrinkle to this
one lawyer i spoke to this this morning
mentioned is what is the or else if it's
just a fine if you don't get vaccinated
that's more likely to stand up to a
court challenge if it's something else
that we don't yet know
maybe it won't i think almost certainly
there is going to be a legal challenge
to this
i have no idea what the outcome of that
would be
one thing we know is that vaccine
mandates work now that doesn't tell us
whether they're legally
okay
and that doesn't tell us whether they
are morally okay those are different
issues which each of us can grapple with
and i tend to think that they are okay
but vaccine mandates work
and despite all of the hyperbolic and
histrionic claims every time such a
mandate is put in place that everybody's
going to quit
20 of the nypd is going to quit we end
up with between half and one percent of
any particular workforce saying that's
too much and i'm going to bail so they
they do work
uh the reality is that at some point
we don't know when my hope is that it's
sooner but it may be years at some point
covid becomes less severe that's
generally
the evolution of these viruses check out
my interview again with vincent
racaniello from a few weeks ago
once that happens
it would seem logical that the covid
vaccine would go back to
being the same sort of status as the flu
vaccine which is some people get it and
some people don't and it's not a big
controversy uh in this way
let me know your thoughts about what new
york city is doing um and i i'm you know
less i'm less curious legally courts
will sort that out i'm less curious in
terms of efficacy we know that they work
morally speaking where are you on
vaccine mandates like this you can find
me on twitter at deepakman and remember
that tomorrow
i'm sorry one week from today not
tomorrow one week from today is the the
next david pakman show viewer town hall
it'll be december 14th
6 p.m eastern time eastern time we'll
take a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the disco starter set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
i've been using it for a while now i'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell check out disco try out
the products for yourself you will like
the results and you'll get 30 off when
you go to
letsdisco.com pacman or just enter the
code pacman the link is down below
the david pakman show does
truly depend on your support to fund the
daily production of this program we have
employees i try to be a good boss we
offer benefits and health insurance
contribution retirement account etc i
try to be a good boss and we try to put
out a quality product every day
and the last half of 2021 has been
really tough in terms of memberships i
don't
often speak in you know terms these
frank you you always have to pretend
everything's always going as well as
ever but the last six months have really
been tough and it makes sense because a
lot of elements of the economy have been
very tough but if you're someone who can
put a few bucks a month towards a
program that you presumably value if
you're in our audience i would love for
you to sign up at joinpakman.com and you
can use the coupon code better21
and i will make one other offer to you
which is
if you pay full price for a year
membership meaning 60 bucks i'm glad to
send you a free david pakman show
t-shirt of your choice just email info
davidpakman.com and let us know once
you've signed up remember it's got to be
a full price yearly membership i mean we
can't we can't lose money right uh
otherwise it's counterproductive but if
you buy a full price yearly membership i
will gladly send you a free t-shirt just
reach out when you sign up
joinpacman.com is the place to do it i
want to say something to both the left
and right here at least i want to
address the left and right
about something that i think both sides
need to hear
but for different reasons
if you've been watching joe biden for
the last couple of months and i've
covered a ton of the events that joe
biden has done you might have noticed
something is up with joe biden's voice
and he's had a cough quite frankly for
months now there may have been some
breaks there where it was not a
consecutive cough for the full period of
months but it's been going on for for
months at this point in time joe biden
is the president of the united states
the president of the united states
health is a matter of national security
and of global importance there's no
reason to downplay that so it's okay to
be wondering
what's up with that cough
what's up with the strained voice what
is going on
biden had a cough months ago and his
voice sounded strained and there were
questions then
it may have gone away for a little bit
maybe not it's now back
now the white house says it's a cold
that he got from his grandson okay that
may well be true and it is fine to ask
in good faith what is going on
and to the extent that we believe the
white house is being upfront
that's what it is and the left shouldn't
attack people
asking
what is going on with joe biden's cough
and voice i've wondered what's going on
i know many of you have who comment on
it during my streams with folks who are
joe biden's age sometimes colds and
coughs just can linger for months it's
completely plausible that that's the
explanation there's no issue with asking
about this or being worried about it or
saying the white house should be
transparent about it now that that's for
those on the left
on the other hand
there are bad faith actors on the right
who are number one
weaponizing joe biden's cough to make
points about coveted policy and other
things
and number two a lot of those very same
people had no concern at all about
donald trump's health his cognitive
health and his physical health
throughout all of donald trump's
administration so let's take it step by
step
biden's cough is being used
to ask questions like the one i'm going
to play for you now where fox news
reporter peter ducey
says to jen saki isn't biden bad for
exposing people by breaking covet
protocol
by being at work when he still has the
cough
one more topic to follow up on some of
the questions from earlier
the president was hoarse and coughing
today a lot of people in the workforce
are encouraged not to go to work if they
are exhibiting those symptoms even if
they are fully vaccinated so are the
rules different for the president
the president again was tested uh as we
put out in some in a transparent piece
of information from his doctor where he
received a response quickly from that
test
enable him enabling him to proceed
people also had he had a cold uh which
is what you know uh from the information
put out by the doctor but as you know
from your own experience it is possible
to test negative
several times before there's a positive
test so is there any concern about
having him at work while he's got these
symptoms even if he is showing negative
i i can assure you uh that the president
follows every protocol he wants to keep
everyone safe in the white house and
that's why
obviously he we consult with the doctor
and we put out that information to make
it available to all of you go ahead okay
so
while it is true that sometimes people
test negative for a while and then they
test positive joe biden has no other
symptoms that we know of he's had this
cough for if i'm honest he's had it for
months
weaponizing it in this way
to make it about
covet protocol is absolute and total bs
but more importantly when trump seemed
to be having cognitive issues these very
same people said nothing they were
silent about it trump asked where is
rudy giuliani when rudy was sitting
right across the table from trump
trump got off air force one wandered off
looking for his limo had to be brought
back by a secret service agent trump
helped down the ramp at west point trump
glitching when trying to speak trump
asking about the oranges of an
investigation and these people said
nothing
until he took a dementia test which they
say wow he aced a really difficult test
which actually isn't difficult when
trump then had coveted we knew they were
lying we knew they were lying about when
did trump first get it we knew they were
lying about when did how sick was trump
asked
did trump need oxygen dr sean connelly
saying he's not on oxygen no no no but
did he need it well i don't want to go
backwards when did he last test negative
let's not go to the past let's go to the
future
i cared about that
and i also care about joe biden's cough
biden having a cough and a strained
voice for months is not great and i want
to know everything there is to know
about it leftists should understand that
it's okay to ask about that but the
right wingers who said nothing about
trump's physical health during his
during his hospital stay and said
nothing about his cognitive health
throughout the presidency are just bad
faith actors and um we we know exactly
what they're doing we know exactly why
they're doing it and it is another
example of they claim that these are
their principles but as soon as the
principles are inconvenient they
abandoned them and we're going to talk
about that sort of underlying topic next
as well
today i bring you the next installment
the latest episode in these are my
principles
until
they conflict with the facts and this is
a really common theme on the right when
there is a shooting involving a black or
muslim perpetrator or a violent protest
with property damage or some horrible
murder the right is very quick to say
it's about the parents blame the parents
single-parent households are to blame
liberal households are bad for not
instilling the right values in these
perpetrators parents parents parents and
then we have a situation where the
parents are really to blame and have
been criminally charged and now the
problem is the school where the shooter
went what
this is beyond parody but it's what
they're doing
when this horrible school shooting took
place in oxford michigan
the parents of the teenager who
committed the shooting have actually
been charged for involuntary
manslaughter and then they went on the
run police eventually found them they've
now been arraigned formally charged they
are being charged because of the
allegedly unrestricted access that their
son the shooter had to the gun that he's
accused of using in the shooting
finally we're holding the parents
accountable right fox news and
right-wing media should be cheering and
saying we are so glad that finally the
focus is on the family and oh they're
not no
here is fox news host judge jeanine
pirro
saying we've got to blame i hope you're
sitting we have to blame the liberal
school personnel
at the school
for this shooting you really can't write
this stuff
and then
there's oxford michigan with ethan
crumbly who shot and killed four
students and injured seven others
including a teacher
for no reason because liberal school
personnel should have known crumbly had
a gun or at least had access to one but
never bothered to ask
the very reason they told his parents to
come to class instead of suspending him
immediately and then they let him go
right back into class so
this time it was the fault of the school
workers who didn't act to take away the
gun from their kid this time it's the
school workers fault so fundamentally
what is this really about
it's about the parents being trump
supporting right wing nuts there's no
reason to mince words there's no reason
to pretend it's anything else the
michigan school massacre suspect's
mother
wrote a letter to trump
praising trump for his support of gun
rights gushing about her ability to be a
realtor and have her guns with her she
praised trump for the border wall she
complained about parents at other
schools where the kids come from illegal
immigrant parents and don't care about
learning as she said
that's what this is about the principle
of look to the family look to the
parents
that they so dearly cling to when it's
convenient
flies away like
dandelion spores
once the principle is no longer
convenient the way it is here because
the parents are trump supporters that's
all it is
and this is another reason why i
encourage you not to get sucked into the
principles black hole with these right
wingers you
something i've experienced so often when
i take calls from the audience and in
other situations is david please tell me
where you are on the principles of uh
this or that i'm for freedom family and
non-aggression those are my principles
great how do we solve climate change on
the basis of your principles and it goes
nowhere
principles are valuable
in creating a baseline for solving real
world problems and figuring out specific
situations but the principles alone
don't solve the problems for you unless
you know how to apply them and maybe
most importantly it's a waste of time to
argue principles with these people
because they don't even really stand by
the principles when the principles start
to contradict their preconceived notions
of how the world should be organized now
should we give
judge jeanine credit for blaming school
personnel
instead of critical race theory yeah
maybe right i mean given the environment
i sort of expected that's the direction
she would go she didn't but the parents
are no longer a source of concern for
pro-family
advocate judge janine pirro let me know
your thoughts we're going to have more
on this on the david pakman show
instagram find it at davidpakmanshow and
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david.pacman we'll take a
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today stanley mcchrystal retired united
states army general and also author of
the very interesting book risk a user's
guide i really appreciate your time
today it's great to have you on
well it's my pleasure david thank you
so
you talk in the book about how we all
have a sort of
immune system to deal with risk that
evaluates risk and is is sort of in an
iterative way
uh analyzing what are acceptable and
unacceptable levels of risk in life can
you talk a little bit about how the
system operates
how it's developed where it comes from
absolutely as we started studying for
the book we first came to the conclusion
that the greatest risk to us is in fact
us
and we came upon the analogy to the
human immune system and the human immune
system is a miracle
it basically
detects threats that are ingested by our
bodies
analyzes each one for their threat to us
responds normally destroys them if
necessary and then learns from that
process and that's the principle behind
vaccination
and it does that about 10 000 times the
day they estimate on things that could
make us sick or kill us and yet we don't
have to spend much time thinking about
it unless the immune system doesn't work
well organizations and actually
individuals
have what we call a risk immune system
and that's a series of 10 risk control
factors like communication
narrative action
timing
leadership things that
form a holistic ability to respond and
what this really says is
we can't predict every risk or threat
that's going to approach us we're just
not that good and in a complex world
it's in it's a fool's errand to try but
what we can do is make ourselves more
resilient make our organizations better
able to respond to those things that
come at us from every direction and of
unexpected form
i want to kind of build up to big
organizations like the military and
large corporations but maybe we could
start just with an example at the
individual level i remember when i was
18 i got a motorcycle
and my parents didn't like it but i
think they thought if they tell me get
rid of it it'll make me want the
motorcycle more so i think it was sort
of like a let him get it out of his
system thing and i had an experience
where i hit a little bump the front
wheel came down and the handlebars
started getting a little squirrely and
at that point i it was a fraction of a
second where i said this is beyond my
risk tolerance i realized it's too
dangerous and i got rid of it
now that one instant decision
i'm guessing is coming cumulatively at
the end of a whole bunch of different
inputs over the course of my life up to
that point that allows me to intuitively
assess that the risk here now exceeds
the reward how does that system get
built up over time
well over time you first learn the
ability to know what's important to you
typically when you're about 18 when i
had a motorcycle as well
i was interested in being cool and going
places not spending a lot of money to do
that and so that became a very high
priority for me and i was able to sort
of compartment away the idea that i
would set the bike down and get scraped
up which i did
and and other things like that and so
you start with prioritizing what's
important and then as experience comes
you also learn
that things can happen in the military
people talk about new soldiers being
scared in combat well the reality is
every brand new soldier thinks they're
bulletproof
until they realize they are not
so it is older more experienced soldiers
in fact that have a better appreciation
for what the dangers of combat can bring
and they tend to be more cautious they
tend to to do more things to prepare
effectively to wear body armor to do all
those things so we will learn through a
lifetime what's important to us what
we've got to protect
and then we also learn
what are the things we have to do to put
in place protections in some cases it's
modify our behavior in other cases it's
use different equipment have a car not a
motorcycle things like that
when it comes to the military it seems
that there's this additional
component that that has to
fit into the risk calculation which is
that
elected officials who are outside of the
military make decisions about what they
want the military to be doing so i mean
thinking about iraq as an example we
could we could do an assessment of the
kind of risks of that mission
from from a strategic and tactical
standpoint
that doesn't really seem to account for
the political motivations that exist and
even thinking of doing that in the first
place so how does an organization like
the military where risk assessment is so
important deal with the fact that much
of what is being done is is politically
oriented
well you hit a good one here because
david because these things are often
attention
uh you may have policy makers who want
to accomplish something and they're
they're prepared to accept great risk to
the force so they can do that because
they think that the overarching
objective is important and as long as
everybody is informed and aligned on
that then you can operate pretty well
the problem is when you have them
intentions like in mogadishu in 1993
there was this mission creep and the
force on the ground thought that their
mission was to get farad hadid they did
a number of operations the risks grew
higher and then when it ended up on the
night of 3 4 october 1993 with the big
fire fight in which 18 americans were
killed policymakers recoiled because
suddenly that level of loss was a
domestic political risk that they
weren't prepared to accept
and so what had happened is you can find
people can wander away
from being focused and aligned on the
real risks to something and then
unexpected outcomes
produce really difficult circumstances
did you have situations where you were
analyzing a situation or a mission
uh from a risk standpoint in the way
that the military does it and then when
you present it to an elected official
you realize that you're you guys just
are not on the same page that the risk
assessment the way you're doing it is
disconnected from their political
priorities
well in fact and and often their
political priorities aren't perfectly
aligned in their own minds because they
just haven't thought through it enough
so for example during the war in
afghanistan there was a great concern
over american casualties
and i absolutely get that the people
that you're serving with you don't want
them injured or killed
at the same time a policy maker be may
be saying the important thing is to
prevent any american casualties
well you can't accomplish the mission
if you don't accept some level of risk i
go to the loss of ambassador chris
stevens in north africa a few years ago
and there was this call that chris
stevens should not have been in benghazi
he should not have been at a location
where he could be at risk well i would
argue if you don't want him at risk put
him in ohio
the problem is
there's a different risk he won't
accomplish any diplomatic
objectives
so you've got to understand what the
overall requirement is and then temper
your risks according to that and too
often we have policy makers people on
the ground and different players not
aligned with a common understanding of
what the actual
mission is and what the risks involved
are how could those things be better
aligned because it seems fundamental to
the way that that a military operates
which is the military operates in one
way
whereas their missions are often guided
by different considerations and it
creates this conflict that you're
talking about or this incongruency maybe
is there some way that it could be
organized differently so that those are
better aligned
well first is communication and of
course a clear narrative provided by
leadership you know and the military's
not clean on this it's not like the
military's got it right and other people
don't sure if if you give military
people a requirement often they will say
well the
thing that is least risky to us is to
use massive fire support
you know pummel lit the area go in and
occupy and that reduces the risk to our
soldiers and we will accomplish the
overall mission but if in doing so you
alienate the population or you create
popular
resentment around the world to what you
do then what you've done is you've
actually lost the big objective
by trying to reduce risks at the local
level in afghanistan we had a period
going into an area in helmand where the
local commander used a term called
courageous restraint
we are going to have our soldiers
operate in a way that is actually
riskier for them their personal safety
but it's more aligned with what we have
to do to win the support of the afghan
people and that's where this
communication has to occur because
makers can see soldiers out accepting
risk and they go no i don't want them to
accept risk
when in reality you got to be focused on
what's going to produce the most
important outcome the overall mission
that you're there for
in in the midst of these missions you
know sometimes we hear that
not that it's easy but that it's typical
that individual service members will say
you know i i'm not here because i
decided that this is the mission we
should be doing i'm here i'm a cog in
the wheel or i'm doing my part and
there's you know a chain of command etc
and the political considerations are not
important but then in in the later years
of the iraq war in particular as i
remember it vividly
we started to hear more stories from
people coming back and saying when we
were there we were talking about if this
was their opinion
why are we even here iraq didn't do 9
11. i don't understand what we're doing
and that started to become a factor for
some not for all obviously many many
believe that that we should have been
there
can you talk a little bit about the how
common that is and how it impacts
service members to be on a mission that
they may think is not one that should be
even on the table i think it's very
common in almost every
war and it comes partly from a
misalignment on what the actual mission
is and this also comes when the
frustration if you don't think you're
accomplishing it many people don't
understand that in 1864 president
abraham lincoln thought that he was
going to lose re-election and he thought
he was going to lose re-election because
people in the north had soured on the
war and particularly in the eastern
theater they had not seen a tremendous
amount of success
and so frustrating frustration soldiers
were saying i am fighting in a war that
we are not winning and therefore
i'm not accomplishing anything
and so that happened in afghanistan that
happened in iraq you also see things
that
you know with your iraqi partners or
afghans you see corruption or a lack of
effectiveness and you become cynical you
go why am i here doing my best and risk
in my life when in fact the people who
we are theoretically helping aren't
doing an equal amount
that's that's age-old you'll never do
away with that
you do try to address it so that
soldiers understand but then you also
try to make sure soldiers understand the
overall purpose of their mission it's
really important for commanders and
political leaders to constantly explain
to soldiers why are they doing this
if i think of soldiers in the
philippines in 19 early 1942 as the
japanese were
moving to conquer it which resulted in
the bataan death march many of them felt
those they'd been abandoned and there
was no point in trying to defend
something that was indefensible
and it gets down to communication and
leadership
when it came to afghanistan because this
is an area that that you know well
um and the recent withdrawal that
president joe biden carried out um my
perspective was when donald trump
proposed it i liked the idea and when
joe biden did it i liked the idea and my
belief is that the problems that took
place would have taken place no matter
when it was done and that fundamentally
as you talk about the big picture versus
the nitty gritty it was the right thing
to do do you have thoughts about how it
went given that you spent so much time
there
yeah i'm probably more forgiving on the
actual problems at the end and some
people might be and the first reason is
when president trump did the doha
accords and agreed that americans would
leave by one may 2021 he was ending the
forever war and that was what the
consensus of the american people really
wanted to have happen yes and so the
next 18 months the taliban didn't attack
americans because it wasn't in their
interest they just wanted us to leave
the danger was from al qaeda and isis
who had a reason to want to attack us on
the way out so as this small american
force was down about 2500 people when it
came time to reduce that force and begin
the actual withdrawal
you're going to have increasing risk as
it gets smaller because less ability to
defend yourself
now of course that the question is why
can't the government why couldn't the
government of afghanistan maintain
legitimacy and its military
maintain coherence during that process
well what i would say is the afghan
government struggled with legitimacy
from the beginning
partly but their own fault and partly
for factors but also the taliban did a
really good information warfare campaign
so that right after the doha accords
were signed for 18 months they went
around the country and they said as soon
as the americans leave we're going to
flip power here and so no no rational
afghan
official or military wants to be the
last person killed in a losing cause
so the taliban didn't conquer
afghanistan they occupied it
you know when when the air went out of
the balloon
i i know that we we say it's an
intelligence failure by american
intelligence community or military not
to know that was going to happen
and i would say this is more art than
science it it was hard
so
i don't think it was
went like we wanted it to i don't think
the overall outcome certainly doesn't
make anybody happy
but but i don't think it was the fiasco
that is sometimes described there were
risks involved and people knew that do
do you think it would have been just as
chaotic had donald trump stuck to his
original timeline
um yeah i think the risk of it would
have would have been there i don't think
that would have changed the risk of that
you can't guarantee it would happen but
i don't see any reason to believe it
would have been different fair fair we i
guess we should talk a little bit about
organizations and corporations when we
talk about risk just to go to back to
the start of our conversation we've
talked about individuals in the military
it seems one of the unique things about
the idea of a corporation is that the
corporation is a legal entity it's an
idea
but it's made up of individuals and
because of
the size of some very large corporations
as well as a kind of imbalanced risk
reward for the individuals where they
could make a decision that has the
potential to make them a lot of money
but has relatively little downside
because at the end of the day there is
this apparatus called
an s corporation or a c corporation that
that exists there does that skew
risk calculation for large corporations
and could it be a factor in these
situations where you hear about big
corporations doing bad things whether
they are environmentally or legally or
whatever the case may be i think it can
i don't think it always does that but if
we forget that corporations have a
responsibility as an entity think of
them as a huge person they still have a
responsibility for their conduct and and
for things that they do
but there is this idea that if you're in
the herd and you're doing something you
know is wrong it's like being at a a big
social event everybody starts acting
stupid you know they're drinking too
much or they're rushing the stage or
whatever they're doing
there's this ability to think you are
anonymous in the crowd
and sometimes you were incentivized to
make a lot of money i think during the
roll-up to the
uh real estate crisis 2008
there were a lot of people who knew
things were not good but yet they are
making a lot of money at the moment and
they go well i'm just a small entity and
a big thing and what's the chance that
the big thing is going to collapse
and of course the reality is the big
thing is made up a lot of small things
so it can collapse so if there's a moral
licensing there's a moral hazard
that you can
think you don't have the same level of
responsibility because of that
since you're just a cog in the in the
large wheel
the book is fascinating it's called risk
a user's guide we've been speaking with
the author stanley mcchrystal retired
united states army general i so
appreciate your time today i really do
david thanks very much for the
conversation
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow well it's happening
again as we continue to wait and see
whether there will even be an attempt
made to hold donald trump accountable
for his various actions while president
related to the january six trump riots
donald trump appeared sunday night on
mark levin's fox news show
and he admitted to the crime of
obstruction and it is not the first time
that he has doesn't done it trump
straight up told mark levin
i fired james comey
if i didn't he would have taken down the
president he would have taken down me
this is an admission that trump's firing
of comey was deliberately calculated to
stop the progress of an investigation
of which trump was a subject and which
trump calculated would ultimately come
back to hurt him this is obstruction of
justice let's take a look at this first
clip
the content is also part of a
broader
of hilarity and horror which is that
donald trump was on mark levin's show to
promote his picture book and you might
be saying what do you mean a picture
book
yeah we covered a week or two ago like
many past presidents donald trump has
put out a book
unlike past presidents donald trump's
book is a picture book with captions
that read like tweets many of them are
insults about people like nancy pelosi
and others i mean at every layer at
every level it's completely pathetic and
humiliating but donald trump is
promoting it anyway so let's get right
into the moment in question here
i would say listen carefully but you
barely need to listen carefully to
understand what it is donald trump is
saying here the most incredible things
don't forget i fired comey had i not
fired comey you might not be talking to
me right now about a beautiful book of
four years at the white house
and we'll see about the future the
future's going to be very interesting
but
i fired comey that whole group
and now that group is coming back again
i mean it's not
believable it shouldn't be allowed to
happen shouldn't be allowed to happen i
fired comey
and if i hadn't you might not be talking
to me right now
so you knew
that comey continuing to investigate
might be bad for you and you fired him
to interfere and obstruct with the
investigation interfere with and
obstruct the investigation
that's obstruction of justice trump says
i couldn't have survived
if i did not fire james comey and in
this next clip and now it's
this is a former president guys trump
even raises the term deep state that it
was deep state actors
off the wall bonkers stuff from anyone
never mind a former president of the
united states in the words deep state
but they've been there for a long time
they've been in the justice department
they've been in the fbi they've been in
c.i.a so you're coming into a hornet's
nest
i was going to say before
if i didn't fire comey
they were looking to take down the
president of the united states if i
didn't fire him and some people said
he made a mistake when he fired comey
and now those same people said it was
the most
incredible instinctual moves
that they've ever seen because i
wouldn't
i might be here with you perhaps we'll
be talking about something else
but
i don't think
i could have survived if i didn't fire
him because it was like a hornet's nest
when i fired him they all went crazy
against each other so
multiple admissions to obstruction i
you know we could focus in on the deep
state stuff the deep state stuff is not
dissimilar
from the sort of shadow government
conspiracies we've talked about before
these take many different forms
sometimes
the the gist not sometimes
the gist of shadow government conspiracy
theories is that the real elected
officials are merely a facade there's an
underbelly
of those who really control what's going
on and it's sort of a fill in the blank
choose your own adventure
of who that is sometimes it's the
illuminati
sometimes it's democrats sometimes it's
a pedophile ring the jews is a classic
it could be you know the saudis i mean
every version of shadow government
exists deep state is just a version of
that that's all it is and trump's
promoting it so we're not even going to
get into that
obstruction of justice
donald trump says in no uncertain terms
here
i fired james comey
because the fbi was looking into my
actions and it might have been really
bad
if he were able to complete that
investigation unfettered so i stopped it
think about any other scenario in which
an individual takes actions to prevent
law enforcement from investigating them
it's obstruction
it's obstruction and you all know that
i've said some of you yell at me when i
say it
i don't think trump will ever do a day
in prison i just don't see it and i
still think that that's the case i don't
think trump's gonna do a day in prison
but without a doubt the admissions that
he has now made multiple times the facts
it points to
attorney general merrick garland should
be pushing forward on a trump probe here
we don't know exactly what garland's up
to it doesn't really seem like he's
doing it how many times does donald
trump have to implicate himself before
someone will say okay you know what
let's do it let's look into it statute
of limitations not the reason uh five
years on obstruction we are at four and
a half
we are starting to get
tight on time when it comes to the
statute of limitations on obstruction as
far as i understand but it is not yet up
is it as simple as there's one set of
rules for people like trump and a
different set of rules for normal people
maybe now we're getting warmer is there
something here about
putting partisanship aside
even a democratic attorney general
understands
that opening up the door to the
prosecution of a former president
is a door that he doesn't want to open
and maybe has been encouraged not to
open maybe
i don't know
but
at this point how many times is trump
going to admit what he did
before it's taken seriously and actually
investigated
i mentioned yesterday that we'd be
talking about this briefly today
donald trump has been reduced to ranting
about the 2020 election in what is now
almost the year 2022
to dinner guests who are seemingly just
trying to have have a nice dinner
and when we ask the question does trump
really believe this stuff when he says
it does trump really believe
that he won the 2020 election does trump
really believe that
there were massive dumps of fake ballots
or whatever the case this video that i'm
going to play for you is in the he does
believe it sort of category
because i think that if he's ranting at
people at a random dinner it suggests to
me that he thinks it's real but
he might just be
that much of a narcissist that he feels
like he has to keep the lie going at all
times i don't know let's take a look at
the video and tell me what you think and
also consider
just how humiliating it is
that 13 months after losing an election
pretty badly
this is what a former president is up to
11 months after leaving office ranting
at a dinner to guests that he actually
won and as a little bonus at about the
75 second mark you're gonna see one of
the guys in the background
look at his watch which is just i mean
it's it's bonus points at this point
take a look if you get the same number
which was 63 million as you got last
time you can't lose if you got one
million more it's guaranteed i got 12
million more
no president has ever gotten anything
like it there's never been anybody that
got 12 million more we got
me
because it's us it's not me it's we it
really is we
and we did so well
and then the thing was all rigged and
the disgraceful thing the bail and mail
imbalance was just horrible they mailed
hundreds of millions of ballots
people are getting seven ballots they're
getting six there was somebody
interested upstairs so i got five pilots
sent to me it just happens to be a
democrat too i said what do you do with
them
[Music]
just to give you something positive we
will
bring back this country we're going to
have a great 22. we're never going to
forget 2020 we're never you know the
expression never again we're never going
to let it happen we're never forgetting
it we're going to watch it because we
can't let it ever happen again and we
continue to pursue it and we will
because so many things like as an
example arizona as an example wisconsin
as an example now pennsylvania with
subpoenas all over the place which is
positive in other words real subpoenas
and these people you know these people
doing the
uh whatever you call it because it was
really a protest the insurrection took
place on election day
and the rest was a protest and what they
should be investigating is the election
not what took place that day they should
be because the reason they had the
protest is because of the election it's
very simple
isn't that truly something i mean it's
it's like a broken record
but
an embarrassing
and pathetic broken record and i have to
tell you watching that i realized how
much i don't miss
having those rants every single day in
the corporate media narrative and thanks
to trump being banned from twitter
they also aren't on twitter
but what is the future for this guy he
seems to have completely lost it
humiliated globally the laughingstock of
the world most of the world glad he's
gone with very few exceptions russia's
an exception
russians liked trump
there were one or two i think it was
uh was it turkey and nigeria i don't
remember now with very few exceptions
the world's citizens are glad that trump
is gone he's a legend in his own mind
but his devoted followers want him back
we know that every poll of republicans
tells us that
and um
if we're not careful he could well end
up back in office one last thing that's
just kind of funny
i've talked before about these uh
linguistic tells that trump is lying one
of them is the most famous one is when
trump recounts a story and says you know
they came to me they said sir
whatever he says after that it's a lie
the sir routine as it's been called
um is a signal that trump is lying
another signal trump is lying as is when
he says something crazy and then says
and it's a shame and it's a shame so for
example he'll say you know they did
these massive dumps of ballots and stole
the whole thing and i really won and
it's a shame that it happened that's a
signal that trump is lying a third one
is
and we can never let it happen again and
we can never let it happen again that's
another one of these linguistic tells
that trump is not telling the truth and
uh
the fourth one would be trump is
speaking right that's like a more
catch-all signal that trump is not
telling the truth we have a voicemail
number and that number is 219 to david p
you know um
let me play the voicemail first it's
about
my conversations with dave rubin uh
let's play it first and then i'll
address it
hey david uh i'm just wondering if you
had an update um or if you had ever
recently talked to dave rubin right um
you know he's somebody who i think we
all know what's happened with him but um
he's someone who initially i didn't
really pay much attention to and then
you know in 2016 17 18 you know when he
was doing the whole reform the
you know reform the left anti-regressive
left kind of thing i was like okay it's
cool like i don't agree with everything
he says but it's cool right you
interviewed him around that time sure um
when he was saying he's a classic
liberal and all this
but i think that we've just kind of seen
his evolution into something that is
just completely
you know basically just candace owens
like he's just he is
he's the that's who he is at this point
he's like they're indistinguishable from
each other or like you know charlie kirk
like they're they're pretty much the
same in terms of what they say and what
they believe
um do you think there's anything genuine
to dave rubin's political awakening if
you want to call it and um
have you maintained any kind of contact
with him i'm just i'm just flabbergasted
by him and what's what's happened to him
over there yeah
so as many of you know i used to be in
touch with dave rubin sort of regularly
between like exchanging emails and texts
and sometimes speaking on the phone this
is a long long long time ago before his
political awakening
i believe that
dave rubin's political awakening is
completely sincere
as far as he is aware now i'm going to
explain what i mean by that
most of the time
when people are i don't know how old he
was when he maybe he was 40ish when he
had this complete political
realignment or awakening as he calls it
and left the left and is a trump
supporter now
uh most people at that age don't have
that unless one of two things has
happened one
they never followed politics like they
were only so loosely following politics
that they kind of fell into whatever
their parents supported or friends or
whatever never really thought about it
for the first time they learn about
politics at age 40 and they go oh my
politics are actually this and so there
you might see a shift that's not dave
rubin's situation he was in political
media for years he was on tyt and all
this other stuff
the second one is that you are
bamboozled
by
your own audience and financial
opportunities into believing that you
actually believe this stuff so do i
think dave rubin in his mind goes i
don't believe any of this crap but i'm
making money from it no
i think ruben has actually fallen for it
i think he now is as far as he knows a
true believer
but it's of course been influenced by
the friends he made in so doing and the
money he made in so doing now i did
recently exchange some texts with dave
rubin i don't know if you guys remember
but not long ago i told the story of
when i was leaving a restaurant and
someone yelled to me and now i don't
even it was you jew zionist pig
and i told the story and like
one or two little articles were written
about it and somehow reuben heard about
it
and he texted me saying you were now the
victim of the monster you helped create
and just wait what happens when people
on the right come out and start
supporting you for what happened to you
that never happened never happened and
he was at least again as far as he was
concerned he was completely genuine in
what he was saying
and so i do think that he is a true
believer i do believe that he has fallen
for it in some total
and it's very strange and other than
that i've not had any uh contact with
dave rubin in a really long time that
was probably
we think it was kind of cold out it must
have been early spring it must have been
like when it was starting to get
warm-ish like
maybe april
of this year something something around
that very very strange stuff we've have
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today as i mentioned earlier the bonus
show is one of the many member benefits
for signing up on our website
jointly.com
sign up and we'll see you in mere
moments
[Music]
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get thirty percent off at
letsdisco.com pacman the link is down
below